antonio ferrara réputé comme très
dangereux son évasion intervient cinq
jours après celle de joseph menconi de
la prison de borgo en corse les deux
hommes se connaissaient en fait ferrara
serait un véritable chef de gang avec de
nombreuses connexions dans le sud-est de
la france ces douars da costa joseph
tual
ils ont le même profil les policiers
soupçonnent antonio ferrara 29 ans et
joseph menconi 37 ans d'avoir participé
à au moins une attaque commune
nous sommes le 26 décembre 2000 avec un
sang froid impressionnant ce commando
armé de fusils mitrailleurs attaque un
fourgon blindé porte de gentilly montant
du butin à l'époque 30 millions de
francs le lendemain six malfaiteurs sont
arrêtés dans ce pavillon près de paris
les armes et l'argent retrouvé mais pas
ferrara neeman coni
les enquêteurs les soupçonnent pourtant
d'être impliquée dans ce braquage car
leurs empreintes génétiques et relevés
sur les lieux de l'arrestation montcony
s'évade et quelques temps après on
assiste à l'évasion de ferrara boxant
enlever ce contexte là on peut penser
évidemment qu'il ya des liens entre ces
entre ces personnalités là et vous savez
et le toutes les bandes organisées
fonctionnent avec des systèmes de des
changes comme je vous le disais au
niveau de l'armement
on passe d'une structure à l'autre très
facilement donc au niveau des bandes
organisées aussi il n'est pas impossible
qu'il y ait des connexions très forte
les attaques de fourgons ferrara en a
fait sa spécialité
que ce soit ici un enfer en mai 2000 ou
encore m.rainville deux ans plus tard
les policiers y voit toujours la
signature d'antonio ferrara un truand
qui n'hésitent pas à commettre un hold
up à visage découvert comme l'attestent
ces images de la vidéo surveillance
d'une banque
antonio ferrara sera condamné à huit ans
de prison pour ce vol à main armée
commis le 10 avril 97 à soisy sur seine
quelques mois plus tard il s'évade de
fleury mérogis finalement repris après
quatre ans de cavale
les gardiens de prisons découvre alors
des explosifs dans sa cellule à la
prison de la santé
il c'est quelqu'un qui a engagé la
conversation qui n'était pas avare de
paroles si vous voulez toujours le mot
pour présenter même si bien sûr les
personnels s'est méfié de cet individu
qui est potentiellement extrêmement
dangereux qu'il s'agisse de ferrara ou
encore de montcony les policiers avaient
mis deux ans pour les retrouver après
leur évasion respectives